مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم
تشكل النساء التحرك ضد السلطات في ايران
لتخرج من عباءه النظام شخصيات مكرمه منه
يطالبنا بالحريه ويرفضنا كل اشكال حال
فريده مردخاني ابنه شقيقه المرشد الاعلى
والقراءه المشهد في ايران من وجهه نظر مع
رضا يسعدني ان استضيف في هذه الحلقه من
برنامج حوار الدكتور محمود مرضاني شقيق
فريده وابنه شقيقه المرشد الاعلى في ايران
اهلا بك دكتور على فرانكش
بونجور مرحبا اولا ابدا معك بالسؤال اذا
ما كانت لديك معلومات عن شقيقتك وهل
تتواصلون معها
[موسيقى]
لدينا اتصال هاتفي معها ووالدتي استطاعت
ان تزورها مره واحده
من ناحيه الصحه
[موسيقى]
تفاصيل اعتقالها
اللي الطيبه
[موسيقى]
ولم تم تتوقع بان يتم اعتقلوها
ولاسيه ما كان ذلك في ايطاليا
وهي ارادت ان تكون هناك وعندما وصلت الى
هناك تم اعتقالها باستخدام القوه
دون تركها ان تدخل الى البيت لاخذ اغراضها
وحاجيئها وما المبرر لذلك لتوقيفها
انا غاصب الظاهريه
الامر يتعلق بالانشطه المضاهده للنظام
وهذه دائما التهم التي يتم استخدامها ضد
اولئك الذين
يتحركون من اجل حقوق الانسان
وينجدون بممارسه النظام ويعتبرون ذلك
كفعلا ضد الدين ويتم الحكم عليهم بالاعدام
هناك لا يقل عن سته عشره الفن همم من
الاعتقالات وهناك ايضا قتلى وبالتالي اختي
في
برنامجين على الانترنت
بمناسبه منى بمناسبه همم همم
هذا هذا الامر تم
اداء الى اغضاب النظام مشاركته في هذه
الاحتفاليه
التي زارتها يعني هل هناك يعني اجراءات
همم تقومون بها على الصعيد العائله لاطلاق
سراح فريده
كلا ليس حاليا من اجل الافراج عنها
وليدتي كنت انا شخصيا
بارسال الرسائل همم
باسم امه من اجلي الافراج عن كل
الايرانيين ان فريده هي مجله ايرانيين
والايرانيات الاخرين
وهذه الرساله تم نشرها في كل وسائل
الاعلام
والرسائل وسائل الاعلام والدتك كانت دائما
ضد اخيها وفي هذه الرساله بيت والدتي عن
معارضتها
لاخيها والنظام الحالي في ايران سناتي
للحديث عن الخلاف العائلي لكن ما قبل ذلك
همم اريد ان اتحدث عن والدتك همم بدري
حسين من ايه بعثت برساله مفتوحه تعلن فيها
تضامنها مع جميع الامهات اللواتي لديهن
فتيات معتقلات النظام وتحدثت فيها عن عنف
السلطات مع النساء في ايران كيف تتصور صدى
هذه الرساله لدى السيد خامل اي شخصيا
ان يكون هناك اثر لهذه الرساله
ولكن لم يعد يستمع الى اي شيء
هنا
ليس بسبب هذه الرساله هذه الرساله جاءت
لتبين ان والدته هي كانت دائما وابدا
اخيها وضدها هذا النظام وهي تريد ان تشجع
الايرانيين على المزيد من المظاهرات
والاحتجاج همم بصوره اكبر من اجل الوصول
الى الحريه والديمقراطيه ومن اجل انجاز
هذا النظام الذي بداناه من 30 او 40 عاما
انا الاوان لياتي ذلك اليوم الذي ننتصر
فيها
همم
بالحديث عن ذلك في الثمانينيات نشات
خلافات بين والدتك وعائلتي والعائله غادرت
على اثرها البلاد هل لك ان تحدثنا عن هذه
المرحله وعن طبيعه الخلاف
لا ينبغي تفسير الامور بهذه الطريقه
السياسيه
وضد نظام اسلامي دينيا
هذا الامر
بابي او بامه هذا الامر لم يتغير والدي
غادر منه احتجاجا على النظام
على الحرب بين العراق
[موسيقى]
الحرب اطول مما ينبغي وتعرفون جيدا بعد
سنوات من الحرب كل المجتمع الدولي وبلدان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كانت موافقه من
اجل تنظيمي عمليه سلام بين ايران والعراق
ولكن
رفض ذلك
واذا همم تنديدا على ذلك
عام 1984
وانا والليدتي وكانت حياتنا صعبه في ايران
استطيع الذهاب الى الجامعه وبالتالي قررنا
في عام 1985 بالتوجه الى العراق العراق
دي ولا عوده ولكن رفض ان يعطينا هذا
الجواز وقمت باخراج ابي
وامي واخواتي الصغار بصوره غير نظاميه عبر
الحدود همم
الافغانيستانيه وبعد ذلك العراق ولكن بسبب
غزو الكويت والحرب ولذي لم تكن تستطيع ان
تبقى هناك اضطررت بالعوده الى ايران انا
بقيت سنه ونصف في بغداد
الى فرنسا في همم شهر اكتوبر عام 1986
وصلتوا الى باريس ومن ذلك همم تلك الفتره
انا موجود في فرنسا وهتبعت دراستك واصبحت
طبيبا تزاول المهنه هنا
نعم
طبيب متخصص في الانف والاذن والحنجره
وامارس هذه المهنه مهنه الطبابه في شمال
باريس على بعد 200 كيلو متر شمال باريس
بالعوده الى فريده فريده ليست اول امراه
تخرج من عباءه النظام الحاكم من قبل ابناء
شخصيات المقربه من النظام حيث سبق
وصدرت بحق فائزه هاشم رفا سنجاني ابنه
الرئيس السابق الراح الاكبر هاشمي نفسا
جاني عقوبه بالسجن لادانتها بتهمه الدعايه
المناهضه للدوله هل اعتقال النساء
اذا ضرب الحاجب خاف المؤذن
ايه
الرجيم اسيا النظام
اذا النساء والرجال في بعض الظروف
عنيف ضد كل المعارضين لقد قتلوا كثير من
النساء والرجال
بصوره سواء
عائله
كانوا جزءا من
النظام انا اختي واخواتي لم نشارك ابدا في
الحكم
ان يغادر البلاد على رجاله
حتى لا يبقى بالقرب من خائن خميني او
الخامني اذن هذا هو الفارق بين عائلتي
والعائلات الاخرى
حسب شهاده اوردتها مجله الباريزيان عن احد
المتظاهرين يقول اكتسبت شجاعه من النساء
لماذا كانت النساء اكثر شجاعه من الرجال
خلال التحرك الاخير للشارع الايراني
نرى نساء ديكتاتورات دائما الرجال هم
الذين يخوضون الحروب والتغاهم من الرجال
الرجال هم مستعدون للقيام باي شيء من اجل
البقاء في الحكم ونحن نعرف بانهم معظم
الايرانيين الرجال والنساء ولا سيما
الرجال هم ضد النظام بكلمه واحده هل الغاء
شرطه الاخلاق انقذ النظام ام اننا سندخل
مرحله جديده من الاحتجاجات حسب رايي رايك
هذا الامر غير كافي ومن ناحيه اخرى هذا
الامر لم يتم اثباته الى الان همم وهذا
النظام هو مضطر للتقهر والتلاشي اذا جاهزه
التعبير دكتور محمود اشكرك جزيلا كما
اشكركم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]